hello I'm Zanna badal we welcome to the
Immanuel Center in the heart of London
for this intelligence squared debate of
when we will be discussing a very
difficult issue that indeed does go to
the very heart of the brexit debate
engulfing the UK our motion is no
backsliding on brexit Britain should
prioritize controlling its borders over
staying in the European single market
now you know after that historic
referendum result in June British
politicians have been grappling with
what is arguably the most complex
political challenge of our lifetimes yet
there is little consensus on what brexit
should actually mean and then there are
voices powerful ones from within the EU
who warn British politicians that they
won't be able to dictate the terms of
brexit in any case and we have an
excellent panel representing all those
views for you arguing for the motion
douglas Carswell the only MP for you kip
the UK Independence Party which of
course firmly backed brexit alongside
him is the veteran professor of
economics Patrick Minford who also
advised Prime Minister Margaret Thatcher
on economic policy against the motion is
the former Conservative Minister for
business and a soupery and with her
bringing an EU perspective is Alexander
sturb who until last year was the prime
minister of Finland so that is our panel
welcome to you all panel
let me tell you what's going to happen
we're going to hear from our four
panelists before the motion - against
and then after that I'm going to open
the debate to the floor first of all let
us have our opening statements from the
panelists and speaking first for the
motion yes please douglas Carswell do
you go no back sighting on brexit Dundas
Carswell now Douglas you resigned as a
Conservative MP in 2014 and then you
stood immediately successfully for you
get the UK Independence Party and you
said that one of the main reasons why
you entered politics was so that Britain
could leave the EU so please do give us
your own opening statement on the motion
thank you
brexit means leaving the single market
we were always very clear about that in
the referendum it's what people voted
for and I think it would be profoundly
wrong to pretend otherwise but if we
were to remain in the single market we
would be bound by a whole range of
public policymaking by officials within
the institutions of the EU rather than
those at home it would preclude the
possibility of us being able to enter
into those trade deals and take back
control of our trade policy which was
one of the fundamental reasons why we
argued to leave the European Union but
leaving the single market does not mean
not having access to the single market
and this is an absolutely fundamental
point to make now the title of this
debate this evening invites us to see a
post brexit settlement in terms of
immigration or trade now I happen to
think that's a false choice the idea
that you must accept free movement of
people as a precondition to be able to
trade is simply not so I I happen to
have here to make sure that i roughly
stick to the time an iphone an iphone
designed in california with chips from
japan assembled in china with software
from india and you know what we don't
have free movement of people with any of
those countries in fact we don't have
free trade
it's for those countries which is part
of the problem of being in the EU of
course we need to be able to control our
borders but as I found a member of that
leave as you keeps only MP a hundred
percent of the UK parliamentary party as
someone who's campaign to leave the
European Union for twenty years I can
tell you we are not looking to close our
borders I personally would like to see
an arrangement that means we have what
you might call the free movement of
workers not the free movement of people
now the Maastricht Treaty conferred on
every person in the European Union the
idea of EU citizenship that will go for
ponder the implications of free movement
of workers rather than free movement to
people and many of the arguments on the
other side begin to melt away we're not
going to have the idea of free movement
of workers as part of a deal but because
it is in our interest as a country to
have the brightest and the best from
around the world to come here this is
about independence it's not about ending
interdependence and the two are not
mutually exclusive trade doesn't happen
because of official Fiat it happens
because people in different countries
want to buy and sell from one another
the key to leaving the European Union
the prize that comes from leaving the
European Union is to conduct our own
free trade agreements and that means
leaving the single market now
immediately after it happened
immediately after the referendum many
people said it can't possibly work
you're not going to get a deal well the
rest of the European Union has a massive
trade surplus for this country but some
seventy billion a year it's not going to
be in their interest to restrict
cross-channel trade from which they
today are the principal beneficiaries
there are no restrictions on that trade
today I can't see them putting those
restrictions in place and now today we
have in the white house like him or not
a president who supports the idea of
brexit the same pundits who covered the
recent American elections often suggest
that we are skeptics of backward-looking
old-fashioned retro well if we were so
backward looking in retro how come we're
not fading away but we're now the
majority view in this country
maybe it's the European Union that is a
of 1950s ways of thinking they imply
that somehow those of us who want to
leave the European Union are anti Europe
or anti-european we're not we're anti
the idea of the European Union of
bureaucratic construct they claim that
we're against internationalism and
cooperation absolutely not
the referendum result was placed no side
can claim to have a blank check we need
a new consensus we need to accept that
we're leaving the European Union and we
need to recognize that if we do that we
can still be good friends and neighbors
to cooperate with the European Union
thank you
thank you next arguing against the
motion is Anna Sabri now Anna
conservative P you are a very vociferous
campaigner for Britain to remain a
member of the EU in the run-up to the
June referendum and you recently
co-founded the Open Britain campaign
calling for the UK to keep its
membership of the single market and
until this summer you were the business
minister so please do argue against the
motion well thank you very much indeed
and ladies and gentlemen here in the
hall you'll forgive me that I'd like to
just address them in many ways the many
tens of millions of people across the
world who will hear much of this debate
and make it very clear to them this
country is very much still an open
country that welcomes people whatever
the color of their skin whatever their
faith or their race so let's now turn to
the emotion that's in front of you
there'll be no backsliding on brexit and
I say that as you know as somebody who
was a fierce fierce believer in our
remaining within the European Union we
have to honor the vote that was taken on
tomb the 23rd but I also want to say
this because it's really important you
all of you that took part in that vote
on June the 23rd will remember that
there was actually one question on the
ballot paper and that question was do
you want to us to stay remain or leave
the EU there were no sub-clauses to that
there were no other questions on the
ballot paper about well do you
understand single market do you want
more sovereignty do you want fewer
immigrants do you want to control our
borders it was a simple straightforward
remain or leave the European Union and
as we know 52 percent of those people
who voted voted remain sorry voted leave
52 percent if only it had been the other
way around
sadly it was not 52 leave
48 remain it's right that we should now
debate how and what on what terms we
leave the European Union but we should
be tread very carefully if we try to say
that the majority of people that voted
voted to control immigration because you
see Douglass's view of leaving the EU
was very different
I would suggest than the leader of or
the acting leader of his party because
whether Douglas likes it or not
it was Nigel Faraj who you may remember
who stood in front one of the one of the
darkest days in our nation's politics
who stood in front of a poster of a long
line of people fleeing from terror and
from war seeking sanctuary somewhere
else and he said that that's what the EU
was all about he was playing to the
basest of all prejudices looking at
people on the color of their skin of the
race or their religion as opposed to
addressing the real issue so let us also
be very clear about this
we do control our borders you may have
been abroad recently you may have
traveled overseas out of our country and
you remain remember that when you
returned into our country you had to
show your passport and every year
thousands of people are refused entry
into our country so we do control our
borders and of course the other thing
that we do is we control migration by
the fact that overwhelmingly the
majority of people who come to our
country come here to work so I welcome
immigrant workers into our country
because they come here to work and I
believe they add to the rich diversity
of our country and they have done for
centuries and we should celebrate that
so that is the case that I would make
for why we should have the free movement
of Labor and indeed people it is about
work but it's also about that free
movement of ideas so the benefits of the
single market ladies and gentlemen as we
now leave the EU we would be absolutely
mad in my opinion if we were to toss
away
the ship of the single market our supply
change like you saw with Nissan they
rely on that free movement of goods so
that we can do trade and without our
membership of the single market we will
fall back on tariffs and that will mean
that our Ark the goods that we make in
this country will cost far more and when
we sell them into the European Union and
that means in short that people won't
buy them and that means that we will not
have the strong economy we have so it's
in our financial interests ladies and
gentlemen not just for my generation but
for our children and our grandchildren
we stay a member of the single market
thank you very much indeed our second
speaker for the motion is Patrick
Minford now you are professor of Applied
Economics at the Cardiff Business School
in Wales and you are one of the top
economists Patrick in favor of brexit
stating that the UK would be better off
pursuing free trade deals and
controlling its own migrant labor policy
thank you very much that happened good
evening ladies and gentlemen it seems to
me the vote was pretty simply to leave
the European Union in order to become a
sovereign state which I take it to be
the object of brexit then I think we
have to start with the economics and
remember that a sovereign state also
rules the economy we are not ruled by
another state with its economic ideas
about how we should do business we we we
rule ourselves and the economics has
always been central in this debate and
what was the economics of leaving the
European Union what was the European
Union doing that made so many of us want
to leave it I think there were three
things first of all its protectionist it
it levies huge barriers to trade worth
about 20 percent on both food and
manufacturing through the so called
customs union and Common Agricultural
Policy the second thing it did it had a
very intrusive regulative system
regulating all aspects of our economic
and indeed Sparta wanting to regulate
more of our political life in order to
achieve the objects apparently of the
single market so the regulatory cost of
EU are very serious and that was an
another big reason now the third big
reason concern control of our borders
now people say you know there's a lot of
talk about how people who want a control
board is apparently racist and so on
according to Anna but I don't think this
is about race at all or anything to do
with you know intolerance it's a theme
that goes back a long way in economics
that you have to control your borders if
you have a welfare state in order for
people who are unskilled who can't
contribute very much to your economy
gaining a lot of welfare from your
welfare state and actually we did a
calculation that unskilled immigrants
from the EU of whom there are about 1.2
million of whom about a million or
adults cost the British taxpayer each
year three and a half thousand on
average and so what you have is it as a
big third reason and who paid these
bills it was the poorest people in our
country where an unskilled immigrants
settled and this was a gross injustice
and of course it was an important cost
to it to the people who voted for brexit
now how are we going to achieve brexit
given that these are the costs well
there are two ways to do it one is to do
the so-called soft brakes in which Anna
Anna Sabri favors which is basically you
don't leave the EU basically you just
stick around in a single market with all
these things that we we don't like
happening no control over our laws no
control over our skilled immigration how
can that be what the people wanted how
can it be consistent with a vote and how
can it be optimal given that we still
got all the same costs that we had
before that we didn't want no there's
only one way to leave the EU to become a
sovereign state if you have to leave
these institutions you have to leave the
single market you have to leave the
protectionism and you have to abandon
the free immigration the lack of control
all those things I talked about if
you're gonna leave leave and that means
leaving all these things that cause
costs including the single market the
customs union you have to go to free
trade now the last thing I want to say
is this do we need to do a deal with the
European Union
selling into the single market the
answer is no there's a world market out
there in which everybody can sell and
the UK is no exception we have a small
country we sell in millions of markets
around the world we don't need any trade
agreements really only other country and
yes as douglas Carswell ahead has said
an outward-looking migratory control a
green card system but one that is
intelligent in terms of controlling the
costs of welfare of the people who enter
our country and making sure that they
don't batten down on poor people are in
our country
thank you very much indeed Patrick
Minford so now the last of our opening
statements and speaking against the
motion is Alexander Stubb who until last
year was prime minister of Finland but
Alexander you've also had extensive
experience across several government
departments until this summer you are
Minister of Finance and previously
you've been Minister of Foreign Affairs
and European affairs and trade but you
also have a personal connection to the
United Kingdom because your wife is
British isn't she
that's right that's my claim to fame my
starting point before I make my three
points is that I find it almost
paradoxical that I have to stand here in
probably the most international country
in the world to make one of the most
difficult arguments for why we as
nations should cooperate this is after
all the country which in my mind has
created the recipe of success based on
three things number one democracy number
two free markets and number three
globalization and right now this country
is unfortunately on the verge probably
to try to reject a few of those thesis
let me make my three points of why we
should all vote against the emotion here
today the first one is I think a soft
brexit it's the best way to go about it
and I will do everything in my power to
try to make the transition towards
brexit as soft as possible I think it
will take three phases phase number one
is from the referendum to the initiation
of article 50 whenever that may be
face number two is the actual
negotiation of approximately two hundred
thousand pages of secondary legislation
it is not going to be very easy to just
dismantle 40 years of UK membership in
the European Union this will be
extremely complicated from a legal
perspective
it'll be very complicated from a
political perspective and it will be
economically complicated as well face
number three is what we should start
focusing on and that is the future
relationship over the United Kingdom
with the European Union if we go for a
hard and abrupt better exit I think we
will be pushing the baby out with the
bathwater and that is something we
should not do it will not benefit the
United Kingdom nor will it benefit the
rest of the European Union
now I think Britain and excuse me for
using this term should get a new deal
and I think this deal should be based on
three pillars number one common foreign
security policy there is no European
foreign security policy without Britain
nor is it easy for Britain to act
without the European Union number two
just as an OMA fest because you cannot
fight terrorism without the United
Kingdom and vice versa and then number
three to the argument here today I think
the United Kingdom should have as much
of an access to the single market as
possible but that access based on four
freedoms the free movements of goods
services money and people will also
involve people so in that sense you
cannot detach these four freedoms but
what you can do is detach some of the
flanking policies if you don't like
structural policies don't be part of it
if you don't like agriculture or policy
or energy policy or Environment Policy
don't be a part of it but stick to the
Four Freedoms the whole idea that
immigration is a bad thing for the
United Kingdom
I think it's counterfactual you were the
only country in the European Union in
2004 to allow for the free movement of
labour from Eastern and Central Europe
and look at the country which is
prospered since 2004 it was you my third
and final point is this I think the
British people should be given a second
chance
in 2019 or 2020 and this is the argument
the idea of detaching yourself from the
European Union is probably the most
important decision in recent British
history I think there should be a choice
between the New Deal which I call for to
be as good as possible through a soft
brexit and then the second option would
be of membership that is the final
choice that the you cast make because as
has been said here before we are in a
situation whereby people did not know
what they voted for it is very easy to
say brexit means brexit but I have not
found anyone yet
at this stage who can tell me what
brexit actually meets Thanks
so audience we've had the opening
statements from our panelists before I
throw this open to the floor let me tell
you how you the audience here at the
Emmanuel Center voted at the start of
the debate before you heard any of us
because on our motion let me let me
remind you no back sliding over brexit
britain should prioritize controlling
its borders over staying in the European
single market for the motion 20 percent
against the motion 64% don't know 16
percent I should say however that our
audience here in London is not
representative of course of the British
electorate because London as we know yes
London apart from two constituencies
voted overwhelmingly to remain on the
June the 23rd referendum so no surprise
there so can I see hands please okay
fire away thank you
for 46 years and when I arrived it
wasn't just the microphones that didn't
work nothing worked it was a dog
I come from my home in Canada buy in New
York in Germany and this was a poor
country still recovering from the war
it's got richer every year since we
joined the EU I'd like the panel to tell
me too what they attributed if they
don't have tribute to globalization
foreigners like me and the EU thank you
I have a question for Douglas
now given the performance of your
colleagues in the House of Commons since
the referendum or looking back at the
track record before the UK joined the
common market what makes you think that
British politicians are that much more
skillful than brussels politicians I
happen to think that UK politicians a
hideously wrong on many many things but
at least you can sack them at least you
can hold their feet to the fire however
imperfectly the people the people who
gave us the euro which has caused mass
unemployment throughout the European
Union and consigned the lives of tens of
millions of people in southern Europe to
ruin and debt you can't get rid of them
the troika in Greece cannot be held to
account
it's against ordinary people having the
power to hold to account the people who
govern them and he's not a force for
global free trade thank you let's
agricultural questions now yeah
you've got a microphone stand he's been
against trade deals he's argued that
China the import of cheap Chinese goods
has strangulated the economy and he's
got a lot of votes and is now won from
being against it and becoming
protectionist but you're now saying that
we are going the opposite and we're
going for trade deals so that doesn't
correlate with people being really angry
and voting for Trump I'd like to go if
your answer thank you there was another
point there in respect to the brexit
campaign one of your fellow travelers on
the road to brexit was one Boris Johnson
recently quoted as stating that Britain
will make a Titanic success of brexit
now
carry on given that we all know what
happened to the Titanic I regard this
statement by Boris as quite prophetic
question to Anna and Alexander his son
is the single market not integral to the
whole point and idea of the European
Union and therefore a country to leave
the European Union without leaving the
single market would be like a couple
getting divorced and still remaining
living together alright so we have that
question about people angry about
globalization which doesn't really fit
with the free trade free you know well
that you're looking at
well that's identifying Trump with
brexit I mean they're completely
different things the point about the
brexit campaign 92% of our people who
are workers in this country don't work
in protected industries 8% do and yet
actually every car constituency voted
for practices where did those facts come
from them seriously
the brexit debate right people like me
lost and now we need to move on but
there was a very dangerous statistic and
that was you used which needs
challenging you said there were over 1
million and unskilled immigrants in our
country that is not true this um goes
that is not true because your definition
of unskilled now I don't interrupt you
sir so don't you did and the point I'm
going to make is your definition of
unskilled workers includes nurses nurses
are some of the most skilled people in
our country you know and let us be very
very clear on this point about migrant
workers from the ELA you they got up
here to work and they work very hard and
the simple question which needs
answering is when you've sent most of
them home as you intend to do who is
going to do the work that these people
do
I think that one of the reasons why
there is a rising tide of
anti-establishment Politics insurgency
in the Western world is precisely
because there's a feeling that the elite
has stolen democracy in the the demos
wants it back and when I hear Alexander
come here and say that we need to vote
again it worries me are we to be made to
vote until we give the right answer
according to Alex but that is an
outrageous outrageous
- four months one is the comparison
between Trump and brexit I think it's
very difficult to compare the two but I
think the underlying themes are very
similar you know there is an element of
rejecting of the other there's an
element of anti-globalization I agree
with your Douglas that you know there's
a feeling that over the past 25 years
when globalization has advanced a lot of
people have left out they've been felt
that they've been left outside and they
don't have a say and these are issues
that need to be addressed
now the big difference here is UK and it
breaks it and Trump is that Trump there
will be a re-election in four years but
brexit means brexit and you are out for
good is it just one senses Alexander
said that we needed to vote again and
the choice should be between EU
membership or the New Deal what kind of
choice is that yeah he's got the
microphone stand please
so my question is not on the EU itself
on representation so obviously brexit
does me in brexit but my question is the
proposition to Douglas into Patrick how
do you represent 48% of the people by
pushing for a complete severance of ties
from the EU okay thank you
those'll - a long time fair okay a good
evening I'm very grateful to miss this
tube for offering me and those who voted
like me a second chance to rectify the
mistake that we made but I voted to
leave the European Union and whatever
flows with that flows with it and I'd
like to pick up Anna Supre on a
disgraceful slur type comment that she
made of the start I've heard this said
many times about how we control our
borders and anybody if the implication
mean anybody who has concerns over
borders is somehow racist and I'll make
this last point a million people entered
Germany over the last 15 months much to
the concern of many of the residents in
six years time if we stay in the
European Union allowing for the
transitional arrangements every single
one of them people will be entitled to
settle here thank you
you will get a chance to but I I noticed
you will I will come to you for that
because you have a right of reply yes
but I just want to come to Radek
Sikorski who was foreign minister of
poland until last year who i've spotted
in the audience there I'm just picking
up on that particular point there
because 850,000 poles in the UK and
we've had a lot of complaints from your
government and also from the ambassador
here in the UK about the rise in
xenophobic attacks and comments about
the poles in particular I was myself a
refugee in this country I was very
grateful to get protection here from
martial law in Poland when I needed it I
now a migrant worker and just on a point
of fact if you want to get rid of me
send me back to Poland you don't need to
leave the European Union it's enough
that I for three months become a burden
on the public extractor and you can then
do that under the existing treaties
secondly I really don't believe
that retina needs to recover its
sovereignty because if you weren't
sovereign he wouldn't have had this
referendum in Poland we know something
about losing sovereignty and it's
somewhat offensive to hear it in this
way thirdly I would still like to back
the underdog in this debate because much
as I agree with Alex that that this is a
big experiment that Britain is embarking
upon I think the politics of this
country are such that they will have to
leave both the single market and the
customs area my proposal would be that
patrick-man Ford's vision of a
freewheeling free trade in Britain
should be tested and perhaps Britain
will again be pioneered just like she
was in the 1980s when she reversed the
course of history by starting
privatisation if your model works we
will be following you if it doesn't
they're in a generation or so 15-20
years then you can have your second
referendum and correct what I believe to
be your mistake
thank you very much indeed Radek but and
I'm gonna come to you for a right of
reply because that question there about
don't paint people who want to control
their borders as racist you didn't say
that yeah everybody in this room heard
exactly what I said and so I do take
objection because I didn't say that
anybody who wanted to control our
borders or indeed reduce immigration was
a racist I never said any such thing I
will tell you this in my County of
Nottinghamshire there has been an 18%
rise in hate crime people who have come
here to work sometimes born and bred in
our country and second or third
immigrants have found themselves being
subjected to foul racist language and
the sort of comments which are not
acceptable in any society can I just say
to the young man over there makes a
pretty good point this is the point I
really also want to make is about we
have to move forward and we have to
bring people together and we have to
heal huge divisions that have occurred
in our society and don't has to
underestimate them or 48% of people
voted to remain in the EU yeah we need
to hear them bring the women as we like
at the best field yeah okay Patrick
Minford just first of all comment about
a civilized debate and I do think we
should move on and I like very much what
mr. Sikorski said because exactly right
in the 80s we charted in this country
and that was what improved our economy
massively in the following two decades
big reforms of this economy under mrs.
Thatcher so I I'm very happy
I'm very happy to be judged on what I
regard in brexit as the next stage in
our free market movement of reform and
supply-side reform because what in fact
what what the other side forgot to say
is the may be a market of 500 million in
the EU to whom we will continue to sell
but there's over 6 billion people in the
rest of the world who are kept out of
the EU by EU protectionism and in
liberalism that you said you would hang
on you said you would use taxpayers
money to subsidize British businesses
that would suffer as a result of us
leaving the single market you've cited
that are you find it very hard to
understand any good economic free
markets you say you find it very hard to
understand economics but what you have
to understand
as quickly could you answer them the
question from the young teenager about
how do you represent and we've been
older but I don't know so either you mr.
Sikorski I thought you were being
referred to as a young teenager they're
addressing your point I'm sure I know
that the young young man who said how to
represent those 16 and 17 year olds a
lot of them who wanted to would have
liked to have remained in the EU but
they didn't have the vote if you look at
the figures you'll actually find that
the remain side got more votes from
over-60s than they did from people in
their twenties actually there are an
awful lot of people study that's been
damages then being confirmed by the LSE
so as you go through the age groups
young voted much more heavily to remain
and as you go up the age of their age
groups older people include what I was
saying I think what I was saying is that
there is an enormous amount of support
to remain amongst older people and for
leave amongst younger people let's go to
the floor and I'll come back to
microphone yeah lady here
oh sorry gentlemen I do beg your pardon
to see used lights in my eyes yeah it's
alright
teenager here no black siding on braixen
Britain should prioritize controlling
its borders over staying in the European
single market now endangered actually
properly addressing the motion I'd like
to start proposition to actually explain
what they mean by controlling our
borders what it specifically has been
wrong with our borders up to this point
and what are they going to change that
would so dramatically affect how we are
a member of such an important part of
our economy and the global economy thank
you
good evening I'd like to take exception
to something that douglas Carswell said
that we all knew that the you Kip and
the leave campaign had specified exactly
that we were going to leave the the
single market I think that we were told
there could be a Canadian deal there
could be a Swiss deal there could be a
Norwegian deal there could be any sort
of deal and I think the reason we should
be asking for a second referendum when
it comes to what sort of deal we
actually get is we knew that we wanted
to exit but we don't know where we're
going okay thank you
who's got the microphone here yep go
ahead it's - Alex can I remind you that
David Cameron actually went to the EU
tried to get a deal came back with
nothing then we have the referendum can
I also say something that having as
hopefully it will all go through an
article 50 and we'll leave it's exciting
times ahead for us we're part of the
Commonwealth Africa has the fastest
growing middle class is growing at 20%
and I think we can do a lot more deals
with the Commonwealth and we've had our
hands tied
I should just say article 50 of course
is what the UK has to trigger it in
order to begin the process to leave the
European Union yeah I wanted to know if
poor people are the ones who are feeling
the brunt of immigration and the ones
who are losing their jobs to those cob
workers etc why is it that the what
their areas with the highest levels of
immigration that are generally the ones
that voted to remain okay with respect
the lady who asked the question if she
thinks there's any doubt as to whether
or not the vote was about leaving the
single market we were being criticized
precisely because we had established a
very clear position that a vote to leave
the European Union was a vote to leave
the single market it is deeply
disingenuous to suggest that that wasn't
what it was about but it what to leave
the single market is a member
correct of the single market not
necessarily precluding in your view and
other people who thought like you
continuing access in some shape or form
to think along it but that is the thing
that a lot of people now are questioning
whether even that is possible absolutely
it was also a question I think about you
know David Cameron trying to get a deal
on the free movement of people from
within the European Union and so on
mention of Africa you know the
burgeoning middle class and all that and
what about more migrants from the
Commonwealth rather than the European
Union then because of course Britain has
got huge ties with Commonwealth
countries what I would change would be
the control of unskilled immigrants
that's the point that's where that's
where a civilized country has to have
control because skilled immigrants pay
their way and that always was confused
by the remain camp they said mimma
Gration you know is great which of
course on average it is so you like the
point system precisely it's about the
control of unskilled what's entrance
into our welfare system yeah so who is
going to clean the lavatories then in
our hospitals
who is going to pick the fruit and the
vegetables in the fields of this country
because I still want to know what the
definition of unskilled is there are
hardly any unskilled jobs now in our
country and tell you the answer in two
words you have a deal with migrants
whereby they don't bring independence
which is what we cost the welfare that's
what costs the welfare and she's not
litigious said work has come in to clean
the laboratories pick the fruit in the
berries but don't bring your families
yes that's the point and that's that's
the system of work 50% 50% of people in
Boston especially Polish people in
Boston are fit young men we need migrant
workers and we should welcome and
this is getting so heated but yes I'll
try to lighten it up Douglas we have to
be careful with the US UK trade
agreement especially about the
abbreviation because if it's us UK its
you suck agreement and that's no good
I think the core of the matter here is
for all of us is the free movement of
people and then the single market that
was the motion that we were supposed to
address and I agree with the young
gentleman we have not yet been able to
prove what is wrong with free movement
and that is because we keep on mixing
two things we talked about uncontrolled
immigration or even asylum seekers on
one hand and then either skilled or
unskilled labor belonging to the
European Union on the other hand that's
one issue that needs to be addressed and
I simply don't see the evidence what has
gone wrong with that okay thank you
please not the microphone there's an
assumption that being associated with
the European Union continues to be a
good thing by those who wish to remain
and yet they forget that over the course
of the time we've been involved it's
been an increasingly sclerotic
organization please brexit controlling
our borders is more important than
access to the single market hello
I shan't start by stating my nationality
because it's frankly irrelevant my
question is does it not seem rather
vulgar to the panel that we should
constantly be obsessing over economic
interests we should allow to take
primacy over all other things they're
not things which are perhaps more
important than our immediate economic
interests
okay Thank You judges pause well we
wanted to think of this as a choice
between economic prosperity or freedom
and independence
I believe the two actually go together
the most free and liberal and
independent societies around the world
are the most prosperous and in the
future those countries that succeed and
flourish will be those that manage to be
both independent and interdependent now
the EU I believe is is failing it's the
only continent on the planet with the
exception of Antarctica that isn't
growing
it's in more than just a funk it's in a
fundamental
and in some cases an absolute malaise
why precisely because the European
project is about trying to organize the
affairs of tens of millions of people by
grand design and that doesn't work I
believe that if we leave the European
Union we will prosper and thrive you
don't need to be in a political union
with tax-free technocrats and unelected
bankers running your affairs to be good
neighbors and to be open and free and
liberal and it's just where's the
microphone one more thank you very much
I would just like to ask an assault ring
you mentioned arises in hate crime now
everyone in this hall and everyone the
panel is disagreeing with each other but
I'm perfectly certain that we all agree
that we bitterly regret it but I don't
see the relevance of that to this debate
either because are you saying that if we
stay at the single Marty the hate crime
will go back in the bottle don't you
think it's because your previous Prime
Minister called a referendum that's what
for isn't a hate crime you can't change
it now okay Mike might see I met my
chief constable in Nottingham sure and
she was very clear I rise this magista
at this moment 18% higher than this time
last year and she said this is the words
of the chief constable who is not
political and has no views on exit she
said that there was a direct correlation
between the rhetoric and the language
used in the EU referendum debate that
was continuing in a County like mine all
right
the end of the debate before I announce
the final vote to see which side has won
the most votes let me remind you the
audience how you were thinking before
the debate started so no backsliding on
brexit Britain should prioritize
controlling its borders over staying in
the European single market the
pre-debate results again for the motion
20 percent against 64% don't know 16
percent and now the final results after
the debate for the motion 39%
you've gone up against 59% you've gone
down by five percentage points the dope
noes are down to 2% so that was a swing
of minus 12 percent so in a sense
congratulations to this side against the
motion because you maintained your lead
but also congratulations to you because
you got quite a lot of votes you managed
to influence the thoughts so it's been
it's been a lively debate I hope we've
thrown heats as well as light on a very
very difficult issue thank you to all
our panel to you the audience here at
Emmanuel centre to intelligence squared
from me Zane Abbott are in the Emmanuel
Centre in London
good bye